how to stop being your own worst enemy
so I got a great question from one of my
newsletter subscribers Anna who wrote in
to say you know she has his business
she's trying to get started but she
she's constantly shooting herself in the
foot she she's afraid and she
self-sabotage and she's her own worst
enemy she wants to know what can I do
how do I solve this problem so first of
all I an that great question and I want
you to know that you're not alone okay
people do not wake up every day super
excited super motivated ready to tackle
on any fear you know some people want
you to believe that but it's not true
nobody it's always that confident we all
have our moments of crisis we all at
some point self-sabotage we all are
afraid of things as a result don't take
action on it this is totally normal
everybody goes through it
you know you have the only one going
through this so know that now how can
you get beyond it because you don't want
to be at the point where it's constant
and it just holds you back from doing
something important with your life okay
you have to let fear be a counselor but
not a jailer let it get you to the point
where it makes you worried and makes you
heartbeat it makes you sweat it makes
you stress out but you can still move
forward with whatever your goal is so
here are three tips for you okay number
one know where the magic is I had this
great shirt that says your comfort zone
and then where the magic happens you
know let me I'm gonna find it I'm gonna
find my shirt here here's my shirt okay
I love this shirt maybe a little
wrinkled from the full let me come in
here so your comfort zone where the
magic happens this is important and this
is what this is what I will tell myself
right if there's something that I want
to do that I'm a little scared of that's
it I remind myself about right you have
to step out of your comfort zone to
achieve something great right if you
just stay in your comfort zone it's safe
its warm its cozy there's no risk
there's no fear you're just gonna get
the same results that you always get are
you happy with your life right now are
you happy
with the results you're getting you know
if you are than great then just stay
there but if you're not then you have to
stretch you have to step outside your
comfort zone you have to do things that
you're not comfortable with yet that
you're afraid of it's something new
right and for me as scary as that is
it's also exciting it's also a chance to
learn and to grow and if you're not
continually challenging and growing then
then I don't know life stops being
interesting and rewarding so remind
yourself it does it helps me remind
yourself that to achieve something great
you are going to have to step outside
your comfort zone number two remember
why you're doing this remember why you
started your business so you didn't
start a business just to make money like
if that's the only reason why it's not
gonna work you're gonna you're gonna
quit on it when times get really tough
you realize you know what this business
isn't what I thought it was they're
gonna drop it you have to have a bigger
reason for starting this business maybe
you're starting it because because of
your son maybe you're started because of
your mom maybe you're started because
you want to have an impact in this
certain market maybe you're started
because whatever your reason is like you
have to have a reason right you have to
have a reason for starting this business
and remember why you start it has to be
powerful because that reason is what
gets you through if you don't have that
reason you're gonna quit you have to be
a little bit crazy to be an entrepreneur
to get through all that other crap all
the hard times you have to be a little
bit crazy because a normal sane logical
person would give up would stop because
it's too hard so you have to have that
driving reason and so when you have a
tough challenging time think back like
why am I doing this
what's my main reason for starting this
business and if you can tap into that it
will help you get over that fear that
you're facing and I sincerely hope that
you have that powerful reason if not
start a business where you do have a
powerful reason and number three is is
practice so
anytime you do something for the first
time it's scary it's nerve-racking it's
stressful you're gonna freak out the
thing is after you do it the first time
and you practice it it becomes easier
let me give you a couple examples I saw
these videos the first videos that I did
they sucked I was I was a basket case I
was nervous I was sweating I took me a
whole day to do one video nobody could
be in the room with me I had to be alone
in the house I had to set it up I had to
have everything ready
I was anal you know it was it was just I
was so nervous and stressed out and now
you know a thousand videos later it
doesn't matter it was in a room it
doesn't matter what the setup is I look
at the question I get in front of the
camera I think about it and I answer
right it's pretty fast it's only gone
that way because because I practice
because I got better I remember one of
my most stressful moments was I was
doing a presentation in Brunei I was
asked to go speak in Brunei to a group
of entrepreneurs I don't know how many
people in room huge room is being
televised and they flew me you know
halfway around the world to come and
talk to them and I was nervous and it
was my first big international speaking
gig and I kind of hoped you know like
the day before they would call me and
say hey Evan it's off don't worry about
it you don't have to come you know how
you kind of you get so nervous that you
secretly hope they're gonna they're
gonna cancel on you so you don't have to
go do it
anyway they didn't cancel I had to go
and I was really nervous and I got up
when I did it no it was it was pretty
good you know I did an okay job I didn't
I didn't faint you know didn't pass out
nothing super embarrassing they loved it
and now getting up on stage is easier
right because I've been through it so
your comfort zone stretches and once you
stretch it it doesn't go back down it
stays out and you something new it
stretches and stretches and everything
else becomes a little bit easier so
whatever you're trying to do whatever
challenge you're facing right now you
get started do baby steps you don't have
to do like this huge ginormous step do a
little step as you do that you'll be
able to do that step again with
and do the next step in the next step in
the next step and each time you're
stretching yourself a little bit and
gaining confidence to know that you
could do it again you know I look back
and and I enjoy speaking so much and
enjoy me an entrepreneur so much and I
as much as I wished at that moment like
the day before my presentation that they
call and cancel I'm so grateful that
they didn't cancel and that I took that
opportunity because I've gotten so much
joy and happiness from speaking and a
lot of it came out of that one moment if
it didn't happen I I'd be I wouldn't
have as big a comfort zone I wouldn't be
doing as much stuff as I love doing
right now so you know it's totally
understandable that you're afraid and
that you're self sabotaging but remember
those things remember remember those key
things and keep going you're not alone
in this find a way find your deep
meaning for why you're starting this
business take your practice steps take
your little steps and every day you know
you're fighting the battle you'll get
there
believe for those you're watching like
the video thumbs up below thank you so
much for those leave a comment let me
know what you think you have a question
for me put it below make a video
response just like this one and click on
my face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon